Speaker 1: Let's try. Nate from Rhode Island to
see what's going on in Rhode Island. Nate, welcome
to the program. What is on your mind today, Nate?
Speaker 2: Hey, David. How you doing?
Speaker 1: Doing well.
Speaker 2: So I just had a quick
question for you. Are you interested in how you've
thought about paying your models before now?
Speaker 1: Sorry. Have I thought about
paying for miles? Like for my car, please.
Speaker 3: Have you thought about paying
your. I described as an employee slash
independent contractor type thing.
Speaker 1: Oh, not really, no. I mean,
people volunteer and, you know, there's tons
of people that want to do it and it's sort
of a labor of love. But we've not we don't
you know, we have moderators on YouTube. I
think we've got like 2015 on Twitch,
there's a bunch on Discord, Reddit,
etc. That's a lot of people total. It's
really just it's sort of more of like a
hobby type thing. We I don't really see
it as like an employment sort of thing.
Speaker 2: Fair enough. And
then my other question was.
Speaker 3: Did you know when you homesteaded in
New York, that's where you live now, right? Yep.
CBS, I actually just found out, is violating
sick time laws. So I'll be contacting your
Department of Labor to see what that's
all about. I'll look forward to that.
Speaker 1: Well, I have zero influence
over the New York Department of Labor.
I want to make clear to you, Nate. And so
I will be fully recused from that action.
Speaker 2: All right. Well, I will
keep in contact, and you'll hopefully
know when the time comes.
Speaker 1: All right. Should
I avoid New York CVS for the time being?
Speaker 2: Absolutely not. Just kidding.
Speaker 1: Maybe Walgreens is the
way to go. I don't know. I don't
know what their practices are, you know?
Speaker 3: Yeah. As you know, those are
probably the same. They're all they're all big.
All big companies are like that. Breaking the
law in some way, most likely.
Speaker 1: All right, Nate,
let us know how the lawsuit goes. Okay.
Speaker 2: Will do. Have a nice.
Speaker 1: Night. There is Nate with
extremely litigious. May be one of
the most litigious viewers, I would
actually say interestingly enough.